Salut, aujourd'hui une nouvelle énigme comme tous les jours durant 32 jours,
mais avant la nouvelle énigme, la réponse de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous l'avez pas vu, l'énigme d'hier, commencez par regarder la vidéo
puisque la réponse, je vous la donne maintenant.
Pourquoi ce businessman a t-il licencié son veilleur de nuit ?
Et bien simplement parce son veilleur de nuit à commis une faute.
Il a dormi durant la nuit !
Un veilleur de nuit ça doit rester éveillé, surveillé...
Son travail n'est pas de dormir durant la nuit.
Et comme il a rêvé que l'avion s'écrasait, le fait d'avoir rêvé ça, ça voulait dire qu'il dormait,
comme il dormait, c'était une faute professionnel et c'est pour ça que le businessman l'a licencié.
Oui, c'est injuste car il lui a sauvé la vie, je suis assez d'accord avec vous
et c'est pour ça qu'on va vite passer à l'énigme du jour !
Énigme 28, un petit peu littéraire.
Déjà, là c'est un indice que je vous donne !
Qu'est ce qui commence la nuit, qui finit le matin et qu'on trouve 2 fois dans l'année ?
Je ne dirais rien de plus, vous avez 24h pour trouver la solution.
Qui est tout à fait logique et que vous allez pouvoir trouver, j'en suis sûre !
Quand vous l'avez trouvé, mettez un pouce en l'air, qu'on puisse voir le nombre de personne qui ont trouvé,
par rapport au nombre de vues !
Ne donnez pas la réponse dans les commentaires, c'est beaucoup mieux pour que les autres puissent chercher.
Et si ça vous tente, vous pouvez aussi partager cette vidéo
pour propager un petit peu cette énigme et ce jeu des énigmes de l'été.
En tout cas, le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !